pancake dan go ask what's e.coli is that
like hard Carly coli is a bacteria that
can cause massive overwhelming body
infection
icarly is miranda cosgrove okay hi I'm
Ken Jeong
I'm Amanda or so I'm animal Seth hi I'm
astronaut Nicole Stott I'm Jill tarter
Bill Nye here once again to answer your
science questions hallo rights when will
teleportation happen I don't know
happens all the time in science fiction
but that's fiction
no just the information problem alone
probably makes heliport ation impossible
converting something like you into a
beam of electromagnetic signals very
very unlikely just taking you apart
putting you back together would take
extraordinary amounts of energy Oh Joe
Louis it's physical affection Werth
bronchitis asking for a friend
I mean are you french kissing somebody's
lung I don't know what this question is
look if you're making out with someone
who has a cold you know just you know be
advised just be careful you know like I
love my wife and she is always worth
getting bronchitis for and in fact we
wrote that in our vows from Zara are we
saying then the tanning in space would
happen just in virtue of being in space
because cosmic radiation and unfiltered
UV rays when you're in space of course
you're above you know the bulk of the
atmosphere and that makes it a lot more
dangerous to be exposed to the sun's
radiation so we try to protect ourselves
from that for the windows that we do
look through most of them have a UV
filter on them which helps protect us
but there are some windows that don't so
we know in particular what those are and
we try to really limit our time in front
of them et exists oh I like that when
will we hear from et and there are lots
of hashtags here I don't know the answer
to that question I don't know if et is
out there I think it's likely the
universe appears to be well
Tivoli bio-friendly we know about lots
of planets around other stars we now
know about lots of life-forms on this
planet that exist in extreme extreme for
us environments there's a chance and the
only way that we'll know is to look and
when I can't answer that question
watching ton of 90s music video today
and I am wondering where in my brain
I've stored all of these really
non-essential lyrics and if I can clear
that space with something useful now I
don't know what's non-essential about
90s music videos that's central part of
my own personality for sure so I don't
want to devote that space to anything
else at all but it's a really good
question how do we store we seem to be
able to remember an enormous amount of
information the adult human brain has
about 90 billion neurons it has about a
thousand times more connections which
means that if you counted one connection
every second it would take you about 3
million years to count them all there's
a lot of connections in the brain and if
you think that a memory is just a
particular pattern of connections this
ship uses among a large number of
neurons the number of memories that you
could potentially store in a brain is
infinite the bishop or Josh Harris 25
what is the point of spam emails are
they profiting from it what do they gain
from spending random unnecessary emails
when people send out spam emails they're
sending it to thousands and thousands of
targets say you had a million emails
sent out and they're requesting $1 these
cyber criminals are expecting that 1%
will actually bite a lot of these cyber
criminals will treat this as a business
so it becomes very lucrative for them
Bill Nighy assuming a perfect scenario
where the general disasters don't occur
if the earth stopped spinning would we
all feel dizzy I guess so
not a test you'll probably be able to
run how long does it take to get to the
moon and how fast can you go in space
and this is a really great question you
know it it takes about two days to get
to the moon the way we fly to the moon
so we launch off the earth we get going
really fast and we circle the earth and
we do this what they call slingshot
method of then accelerating ourselves
tor tor
and the moon that's all really cool
orbital mechanics that goes on there and
it's really neat to me how we can use
the gravity and spin of our own planet
to accelerate a spaceship off into space
on the space shuttle
we traveled at 17,500 miles an hour the
guys that went to the moon about 24,000
miles an hour can someone tell me well
hi I'm sick after getting a flu shot
that's supposed to prevent me from
getting one question mark one that's
actually a very nice question because
sometimes there is this myth that says
you can get I got the flu from the flu
shot that isn't not the case if you're
already having a cold okay and if you
get a flu shot you can get a little bit
sick from the combination of having a
cold and that flu shot but you cannot
get the flu from a flu shot you have a
better chance of having a weaker flu
symptoms II than somebody else who
didn't get the flu shot you should get
the flu shot this Twitter user cloud
opinion ass at this point hackers know
everything there is to know about every
one of us why do we need passwords now
why keep going to the gym if you're
gonna die anyways passwords are kind of
a necessary evil and hackers really
don't know everything about you it all
depends if you put that information out
there on the Internet
Tony Phillips writes a climate change
question as it gets hotter more air
conditioning is used heating up the air
even more is there a way to cool indoor
spaces without heating up the outdoors
especially in cities
well Tony probably not because what is
the one thing you can count on in this
universe that's right Tony the second
law of thermodynamics heat just spreads
out man
so when you pump the heat out of this
room or the room you're sitting on
putting it outside the outside gets a
little bit warmer but the scale of it I
hope surprises you the amount of heat we
pump out of buildings ain't no nothing
compared to with the amount of heat that
we're holding in by adding greenhouse
gases to the Earth's atmosphere the heat
island effect of cities is for
more from hardscape paved surfaces
buildings are not soil for example and
that's why cities are so hot the AC
thing is a problem but it's just the
hardscape that gets us and that flippin
second law of thermodynamics I'm sorry
whoa man there's nothing we can do out
there we got a deal it's entropy entropy
killing us all all right Joey Pavan le
is there Wi-Fi in space yes there's
Wi-Fi in space you might not be happy
with it because it's not dial-up slow
but it is pretty slow the Fermi paradox
mathematically the universe should be
teeming with intelligent life so why
don't we see extraterrestrial versions
in all directions really interesting
question the answer is we've hardly
begun to look let me give you an example
if that volume of space we need to
explore is equal to the volume of all
the world's oceans in 50 plus years
we've observed only about 1 hot tubs
worth of the ocean maybe it's not so
surprising that we haven't detected
anything yet we need to think in terms
of cosmic times and not human lifetimes
before we decide we're alone because we
haven't found anything
it's face-blindness a real thing or just
an attention-seeking thing it's a real
thing there's a condition called
prosopagnosia which is the inability to
distinguish between faces what you find
is people with prosopagnosia they're
still able to identify people but they
do it in different ways they're very
good at picking up other kids like how
somebody walks or what clothes they're
wearing or what voice sounds like but
they just cannot recognize faces this
twitter user andrew asks what
would I think of next
is there anything that has been courted
in the last decade that hackers haven't
found a vulnerability to do some damage
if you think about your fridge at home
being able to connect to the Wi-Fi or
your pressure cooker being able to
connect to the app on your phone a lot
of these devices are developed in a way
where they're looking for the lowest
possible cost of manufacturing so when
they get to the security part it's kind
of
like an afterthought so until things
change we're gonna still have these
problems with IOT devices Michael Moreno
wondering if the astronauts on the
International Space Station ever get
bored I hope not I was never bored in
space there's the window to look out see
earth below you sharing stories with
your crewmates floating around flying
and you can even bring things that you
enjoy doing on earth so I had the chance
to paint while I was in space my
crewmates played music in space this is
not a place where you get bored thank
you for your questions this has been
neuroscience support ET support this has
been hacking a support and I hope you
learned a little something about space
most of these questions are really good
some of them absolutely suck and you
should be ashamed of yourselves
[Music]